Texas now,
where parts of the Dallas
Fort Worth area look like ghost towns
as an ice storm
wreaks havoc
on much of the southern and central U.S.
Right now,
most people are heeding the warnings
and avoiding the roads
after treacherous conditions
sent drivers sliding out of control.
Crews say
they have responded to more
than 100 traffic related emergency calls.
At least two people across
Texas have been killed.
The freezing weather also paralyzing
air travel.
More than 1700 flights canceled
and more than 2000 are delayed.
Right now,
40 million people are under winter
weather alerts
as officials
warn ice accumulation
could also lead to power outages.
But Texas Governor Greg
Abbott assured residents
earlier today
that the state's power grid is working
and no problems are expected.
Let's bring in CNN meteorologist
Jennifer Gray and CNN's Ed
Lavandera live in Dallas.
Will start in Dallas.
What are you hearing from people there at
Well, you know,
as you mentioned,
I think a lot of people
are simply heeding those warnings
and not coming out
in the droves out onto the streets here.
And that is because the roadways
really are quite a mess here.
We are standing over Highway
75 on the north side of Dallas.
And, you know, we have seen,
you know, trucks and cars
taking it
extremely slowly
out here on these highways.
And you have really seen the sleet
that fell several hours ago.
We have only had one
initial wave of intense sleet and ice,
icy rain here in the area
throughout the day.
But it is really
hardened up on these highways.
And as we go into tomorrow,
that is clearly going to be a sign of
of great concern
because this is going to be even
even more slippery
come tomorrow
after all of this hardens and intense
overnight freeze.
But it has been treacherous
and dangerous
for people who have been traveling.
We spoke with
Amber and Jason
Kelley, who
were driving from Wichita Falls
to Fort Worth.
They left last night
hoping to beat the storm.
They got stranded
almost a little bit past halfway
They spent their entire night
in the freezing temperatures
in their car,
trying to conserve as much gas
as possible
to keep that car heater going.
Decided to leave last night about nine 30
and which would be a normal hour.
40 52 hour ride has already been,
what, 8 hours, I guess.
And I'm sure we have at least three
to four more hours.
I think we came to a standstill
about 11 p.m.
and we didn't move not one inch for
7 hours and something 11, 12 hours.
We didn't move not one inch
That drive
two ended up taking them 12 hours.
They made it safely
but they were stranded there
on that
highway with hundreds of other cars
that just weren't moving
And that is the situation
that people are dealing with here today.
Victor Nelson.
Oh my gosh, what an ordeal.
All right.
So Jennifer,
what can we expect
in the next couple of days?
Well, guys,
unfortunately, we're
just going to continue
to get waves of this once
this ends in Dallas.
We're going to see another wave of this
by tomorrow.
And freezing
rain is the worst case scenario
when it comes to winter precipitation
because it latches on and freezes
to all the surfaces,
whether it's the roads,
your car,
the power lines, the trees, anything.
And so it's creating
an incredibly dangerous situation.
As temperatures stay below freezing,
we got another round of this.
So it's just going to be compounded
over the next day or two.
Little Rock in this as well.
And you can see
it's already moving into Memphis.
So that's another area
we're going to be watching.
And you can see
just looking at the roads,
it doesn't look like much.
So it may catch you by surprise,
but you are going to slide.
There's no way you can drive over ice.
It is just incredibly slippery,
especially for those bridges
and overpasses.
We could see up to a half an inch of ice
in those areas shaded in blue,
about a quarter of an inch.
And the pink,
you see all the ice reports of sleet
and ice
anywhere from Texas to the Ohio Valley.
So this is far reaching.
We have seen more than a quarter
of an inch of ice across
Arkansas, Missouri, Texas,
about a quarter of an inch to a half
an inch will break those tree limbs.
Guys,
we could see power outages
from this as well,
especially as we get into tomorrow
and we go through our wet third
round of this in just a couple of days.
All right.
Jennifer Gray, Ed Lavendera, thank you.